Ever had an important event coming up, and
baam - huge zit in the middle of your forehead.
Ugh.
Hello cutis wearers, Lissette here for DNews.
Acne vulgaris, also known as those annoying
painful oozing red bumps or dark dots on your
skin, is something that affects almost all
of us - especially during our teenage years.
But what causes acne in the first place and
why is it so difficult to treat?
Well, there are a ton of different ideas out
there - ranging from hormones to diet, to
our genetics and even psychological reasons-
like stress.
Which might explain that pimple before prom.
Although, little is known for certain; Some
of these hypotheses, however, do have more
support than others.
One surprising new study, published in May
2016 in the journal Cell,
blames your DNA.
Scientists from Yale took blood samples of
three individuals suffering from acne and
discovered that all three samples of DNA had
mutations within the gene
NEK9.
This gene is responsible for hair follicle
production on your skin.
But, this mutation causes a defect in the
follicle which makes it produce large blackheads
and acne instead of normal hair.
According to the lead researcher, Dr. Keith
A. Choate “all acne is dependent upon hair
follicles,”.
So it makes sense to look at the genes responsible
for hair production in our search for what
causes acne.
It’s an exciting new path of study.
Now the Yale researchers looked at one specific
type of acne, called nevus comedonicus, but
a meta review of many studies on different
types of acne states seem to suggest that
your mom and dad might be the problem.
The review found that acne’s heritability
is actually around 80% for first degree relatives.
So if you’re parents had acne, chances are
you will too.
Another potential culprit might be naturally
occurring bacteria in your body.
While research is unclear, there is some evidence
that bacterial organisms like
Propionibacterium, a common bacteria found
on your skin might cause acne.
Some evidence that lends credence to this
argument is that researchers have found that
antibiotics can sometimes help with decreasing
acne.
But, they’re not really sure if it’s the
antibiotic’s anti-inflammatory or anti-bacterial
properties that are doing the job.
So it could be that inflammation is the problem
and not bacteria, but again no one knows for
sure.
A common idea is that diet can wreak havoc
on your skin.
Many people swear that certain foods
like chocolate or butter cause them to break
out; and hey every body is different, this
may be the case for you.
But when it comes to scientific experiments,
the evidence to back this up is lacking.
A meta review conducted by scientists at the
University of Nottingham’s Centre of Evidence
Based Dermatology looked at many studies that
considered the relationship between diet and
acne.
Altogether they found only one study that
showed what you eat makes a difference.
A diet low in glucose seems to be associated
with better skin, but this is definitely not
enough to make conclusions.
So treat yourself :)
This lack of research and understanding as
well as the fact that there are different
types of acne with potentially different causes
behind it, makes it so tricky to treat.
There is likely never gonna be one silver
bullet that cures it all.
Luckily, for most of us, acne goes away after
our 30s.
On top of this, most acne, as uncomfortable
as it may be, is largely benign.
So, while it might ruin your day, it’s probably
not going to last forever.
Guys, we are thrilled to launch an all-new
Seeker.com, which is home to all of DNews’
episodes, plus articles, photos, and more
great videos about science, the world, and
exploration.
We can’t wait for you to see it.
Click the link in the description below; we
hope you’ll share any favorite stories or
news with your friends.
In fact, Tara runs down the many reasons why
it may actually benefit us.
To learn more about why acne evolved, click
here Now
If you’ve ever had acne, what have you found
helps?
Share your thoughts in the comments and remember
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.
Thanks for watching.